all right uh it's been a brutal time for
justin fields over the past week or so
his name's been in the news because of
the whisper campaign that made its way
onto the air last week and the pushback
by his ohio state head coach ryan day
pro day 2 for justin fields is coming up
next week because there can be no
private workouts this year we're seeing
multiple throwing sessions multiple pro
days for some of the top prospects mac
jones did it and now justin fields will
do it kyle shanahan and john lynch
expected to attend pro day two for
justin fields in columbus ohio
is he still in play do you think chris
we've seen the betting markets change
dramatically given
the reality that mac jones seems to be
the guy at number three do you think
fields is still
possibly potentially the guy potentially
i i like i don't know maybe i don't
maybe like that's where i'd go maybe i
would think like you know
mac jones name is written down somewhere
in you know in san francisco's facility
at least in pencil at this point like as
being like pick number three but justin
fields is intriguing i mean how is he
not and i would think how is he not
intriguing to a guy like kyle shanahan i
mean listen i hear everybody out there
everybody's talking about man what would
justin fields look like with those
awesome run plays and everything that's
designed that shanahan does the most
creative run game designer in football
where you add justin fields to that a
guy that's 230 and runs 4-4 and he's got
spin moves and can break people's ankles
i mean that's exciting and i'm sure
that's got shanahan thinking a little
bit i don't doubt that one bit you know
so uh
the the thing that i think people got to
remember here too
shanahan's gonna have a pretty good feel
for these quarterbacks despite
despite what the workout looks like and
of course he's going to go see justin
fields so he could see it in person and
do all that but
you know john beck right who's coaching
feels and wilson and uh missing another
quarter trey lance
he played for for shanahan there's a
relationship there i would bet you
shanahan has talked to beck a number of
times about these quarterbacks a little
bit you know to pick his brain and just
see where they're at and all those
things too so he didn't get to go to the
last one it's good to go see this one i
still think it's mac jones but he's
gonna make sure he really gets an up and
close personal look at all these guys
because they're all talented
you know there's someone i know who is a
former assistant coach and i don't want
to go any farther than that yeah
disclosing identities who is convinced
the jets are taking fields at two don't
know why don't know why
the only person that i've heard from who
would whisper fields to the jets at two
not zack wilson but that that would be
something if that happened especially
given what joe douglas said the other
day when asked about steve young's
belief that wilson is the guy you can't
create the impression it's going to be
wilson and then do the switcheroo
because you're going to have a certain
segment of the fan base that's ready for
wilson and then and then you know how
those jets fans are wait a minute we
were ready for zach wilson we already
pre-ordered the zack wilson jerseys and
now it's going to be justin field so it
would stun me if it happened but if it
would happen let's just say okay yeah
then you got mac jones and zach wilson
at three available for the fourteen it's
a no-brainer that's a no-brainer it's
gonna go it's gonna go zach wilson
i i i it'll go zach wilson i i just
you know listen i don't expect any of
that to happen i don't think justin
fields or trey lance are top five picks
as you've heard me say before
but
uh i would think
a guy like shanahan
would love would love zach wilson i
would i mean you know i i've had enough
conversations again about him and
quarterbacks and all those things and
you heard the comments he made after you
saw josh allen this year you know i know
he's always viewed aaron rodgers as
special and all that and again i i would
think he sees zach wilson as similar to
being one of those type of guys that can
just create on his own and make
unbelievable throws and do that so yeah
i would think that would then push mac
jones into i don't know where he'll end
up going at that point and that would be
interesting certainly but i would be
shocked if that's the case i really
would be and i'd be shocked if the 49ers
is not mack jones at three after zack
wilson the jets at two and then
it's it's gonna be interesting after
that because you know again i don't know
where these last two quarterbacks are
definitely gonna fall after those top
three picks
and again
we're on this topic because justin
fields is working out next wednesday
kyle shanahan and john lynch expected to
be there if robert sala and joe douglas
happen to be there in columbus
for pro day two for justin fields that's
when
that talk will get stirred up that are
they just like we're saying are the
49ers considering fields instead of
jones at three i think people would say
if salah and douglas show up are they
considering fields instead of wilson at
two or they just doing their their due
diligence again they don't have to be
coy we saw yesterday how relaxed joe
douglas now is because
he runs the board after trevor lawrence
he doesn't have to play games he's not
going to trade that pick i saw a report
yesterday and i know that we're in the
low point between
free agency and the draft and every
little thing that is otherwise obvious
becomes news the jets aren't getting
many calls about number two well of
course not of course not especially now
they've traded sam darnold they're not
giving up pick number two
at this point they traded away their
starting quarterback they're not giving
it up right don't waste your time yeah
so yeah it's news but
sometimes you don't need to be told that
the sun came up this morning you just
know that it did right away right now i
i i hear you there now to me again mike
i know we've talked about this a little
bit the the real interesting thing and
if nicole if you could throw up that
graphic of the pics again i mean
this is where the draft is awesome yeah
i'm expecting lawrence wilson mack jones
off the off the board the top three then
you get to four with the falcons
right that one's interesting you know
everybody says they're gonna go trey
lance or at least that thinking is out
there in the nfl community very strong
you know
i don't know if i'm behind the fact that
i think they're definitely gonna do that
yet but you look at them and then you
know i'm just asking you out of this we
know the panthers aren't going
quarterback anymore do you think
the lions after just making that trade
for jared goff
because i know some people think that
like maybe they might be in on justin
fields and all that we'll see maybe
they're at the pro day but do you think
the lions would do that after making
that trade and doing what they're doing
right now
i think they definitely would consider
it especially given the ohio state
connection yeah to chris spielman right
right mm-hmm i i think it would be
difficult for chris spielman to say no
to justin fields if he happens to be
there at number seven and and look
the jared goff trade yeah was in part a
brock osweiler trade you get two ones
and a three
for matthew stafford and to take on the
abomination that is the jared goff
contract because the rams tucked it in
to the stafford trade and they could
have gotten more the lions could have
for stafford from another team
but they got even more by taking on the
golf contract they could justify using
that pick on a quarterback who becomes
the guy
in 22 or 23. now if he becomes a guy in
22 they're going to be paying jared goff
a lot of money to not play
but
nothing stops them from doing it and if
it is justin fields how strong will that
ohio state connection pull chris
spielman in the direction of fields and
spielman has a lot more juice in detroit
than people realize he's got now there
are plenty of chefs in that kitchen
right now yeah including rod wood a guy
who said he wasn't going to be involved
in football at all and based upon the
things he's been saying publicly is damn
involved in football right but
spielman's going to have a lot of
influence on how that goes down you
mentioned the falcons chris mortensen
reported earlier this week that terry
fontenot the gm wants trey lance and
that arthur smith the head coach yeah
that's what i've met ryan
for a couple more years look that's
going to be an arthur blank call folks
and we're getting closer and closer to
the draft one thing we have to remember
even the owners who don't act like they
meddle have final approval ultimately
and who cares what the contracts say if
you want to remain employed over the
long haul and if you want to have a good
relationship with the billionaire who
owns your team you make damn sure that
that person is on board with who you're
using a top 10 draft pick on that's
right that's the way it works so what
are they going to do they're going to do
whatever arthur blank wants to do that's
how that that dispute is going to be
resolved they're not going to go hash it
out over a bowl of chili at panera
they're going to get it worked out by
letting the owner make his preference
known and as i've said time and again
one of the privileges of being the owner
is you never have to get your hands
dirty by saying go draft this guy they
have a subtlety they have a nuance they
have a way of making what they want
known and when you have rich mckay as
the buffer between fontenot and smith
it's one conversation between blank and
rich mckay and the next thing you know
rich mckay goes to see his two guys and
he says i think this is what mr blank
wants right and that's the way it goes
right he's the consular there it's it's
uh you know what what's his what's his
name on the godfather uh hayden tom
hagan tom hagan right right which has
been on tv the last few nights i've been
watching little bits and pieces but um
yeah i i hear you i would think in that
type of decision yes the owner is gonna
stick his nose in a little bit
and quarterback such a big position and
the franchise and the direction it goes
is so dictated by the quarterback right
now in this era of football that yeah i
would think a guy like arthur blank is
going to get involved but to me it's the
most intriguing part of the draft you
know i am one that okay you know you
hear mortensen's report right i'm one
that
falls on more of the arthur smith line
like
you got matt ryan he's got two or three
good years left still he can play that
offense you know similar to what ryan
tannehill did in in tennessee and and
maybe even you know add a few more
things into the drop back pass game you
know and i don't like you know again
trey lance is a little bit of a project
who hasn't played football i'm just not
a guy that's into like projects being
drafted in the top five that's where i
don't believe that and they could use
those resources for for other things to
help their team at pick four you know so
that that to me is the interesting thing
and then you know back to the lions too
you know the jared goff thing i mean
they restructured his contract right so
that's one too where i'm just i'm not
buying it i'm not buying the quarterback
thing and that's to me where the draft
is gonna get really interesting if lance
doesn't go to four
and fields doesn't go to the lions at
seven
you know where are they gonna go i think
it's gonna be the most fun part of the
draft and who makes the move and what
happens after that i don't know but uh i
still think that's a big question
even even though the lions restructured
goff's contract i don't have the details
in front of me restructuring just means
he's still getting his money and they
took on an albatross of a contract there
are millions millions like 45 million
fully guaranteed most of which has no
offset tied to it so if you cut him you
don't get dollar-for-dollar credit for a
lot of the stuff that he's due to make
over the next two years no yeah it
really was a horrible contract it is i i
got some of it just in front of me just
to let you know like if they cut them
this year of course and that's not going
to happen it'll be 40 million dollars
dead money next year it's 30.5 as far as
dead money is concerned if they were to
do it after the the 22 2022 season so
that's still and there's a difference
between there's between the cap charge
you take yeah i know and money you still
have to spend right money
it's one thing to say we got to find a
way to take this cap hit we've already
spent the dollars it's another thing to
say we still got to pay this guy to not
be on the team that's part of the cap
charge that we're taking and i think
with goff a big part of it is going to
be money you still have to pay out to
the guy but but if you take a project
i don't know i i think lance may be more
of a project than justin fields but
regardless if this is your answer for
the next 15 years and you can bring him
along slowly and you're in a division
where they saw aaron rodgers sit the
bench for three years and then become
one of the best quarterbacks of all time
they could justify putting justin fields
on the bench for a couple of years they
got all those extra picks in future
years that they can use to put pieces
around them if they choose yeah to
ultimately
do it um and it's funny with matt ryan
like
that he's got one or two good years left
in him he's not in his 40s i know he's
he's mid 30s i know he's yeah i mean
that's the least he's like the willie
nelson of football he's been an old man
for 10 years he's still got plenty of
football left in him he does i mean
again you know i mean
right there towards still one of the 10
best quarterbacks right on the edge
number 11. i mean number 11 as we've
talked about i mean yeah i mean he's
right he is you could still you could
still win
lots of football games and i still think
matt ryan can take you to the promised
land if he's got a team around him and
it's done the right way so yeah that's
where you know that's where i don't
agree with quarterback at four i don't
you know the falcons do have some
difference making type players on their
football team and uh if they could add a
little depth and you know like we've
seen they've been killed by injuries the
last few years they could be one of
those teams that pops up this year and
we go whoa here the falcons are back a
little bit here let's go baby
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports